Monica Klein is a founding partner at
Seneca strategy she joins this time
Monica thanks off for coming on yeah I'm
sure you describe yourself as pro-choice
I bet a lot of people watching right now
think of themselves as pro-choice so I'm
not tacking for that but I wonder what
you think of what dr. nor them the
governor of Virginia just said that when
a child he described the child is an
infant is born there's a point where the
mother and the physician can decide
whether to kill the infant or not what
do you think of that look Tucker I
understand that you want to go back to a
time where roe v wade was illegal where
women were having to have abortions
which is actually what's been where I'm
giving you time to make a reel to make a
real argument I'm not arguing for the
repeal of roe v wade I'm a very straight
is what you're essentially no that's not
what I'm arguing and please don't be
tiresome the governor of Virginia who's
a rising star in the Democratic Party
just said this there's pending
legislation that mirrors it and I'm
asking you what you think of it that's
it I'm not a big rep right now
reproductive health care is under attack
by the Republican Party 72% of Americans
support the right to choose and yet we
have Trump and we have sexual predator
Cavanaugh trying to repeal roe v wade
and trying to take away our control of
our own bodies this isn't about babies
this is about health care this is about
you attempting to control women's body
okay okay please don't be a robot Monica
you're smarter than that this is the
governor of Virginia just saying this I
just want to know what you think of it
is that okay does that bother you it's a
sincere just happened okay it bothers me
that you are attempting to control
women's bodies right now it's over time
to repeal roe v wade and to take away
choice and everything if you think
you're convincing anybody or if your
unwillingness to address what just
happened today on tape that we just
played is a sign that you can't defend
this and if you can't defend it I wonder
why that is have you paused to ask
yourself as an American as a person what
do I think about that as a woman what do
I think of it have you asked yourself
why you spent so much time talking about
this rather than thinking about why your
party is trying to repeal roe v wade and
control woman's body bring
there are seven states where there is
only one abortion clinic okay there are
four let me know sugar banter we would
if fro the Vedas repealed women cannot
get reproductive health care this is
about a woman's right to choose and you
as a man should not have a single say in
that Wow
do you think that you're making a case
that most people agree with that it's
okay to abort a child in the third
trimester you know trying to put a mouth
and keep trying yeah that the Democratic
Party is hurting children I have a party
is the one that is tearing families
apart underwater
children die in federal custody so whose
party is actually harming children Wow I
just let me just ask you one quick
question I mean this is obviously a
pointless conversation and I think less
of you after it's an honest question
have you thought about it do you have a
real answer to what the governor of
Virginia said or are you gonna throw yet
another talking point at me I mean have
you actually thought about it will you
answer that question at all I have
thought about it and I am Telling You
you say your party is attempting to
change the conversation about roe v--
wade and take control as a man what
you're focused on is controlling women's
bodies but we will not allow you to do
that this is a child who's been born
this is not a woman's body this is an
independent person you pretend that you
have concerns over children when you're
completely fine with ice tearing
families apart and children dying in
federal custody Monica thank you I
appreciate it